and here comes the snot yeah I'm gonna
do the rest of it like this cuz I don't
think I can control it now I think it's
just nasal drip hey what's going on
everybody four first we feast I'm Sean
Evans and you're watching hot ones it's
the show with hot questions and even
hotter wings and today we're having
lunch with Gabrielle Union you know her
from timeless films like bring it on in
bad boys 2 you can catch her on the
landmark series being Mary Jane now in
its final season she has a new book out
the much buzzed about we're going to
need more wine available now Gabrielle
welcome to the show thank you for having
me how are you with hot food I'm very
concerned my house is going to explode
on camera and that concerns me I'm not
sure if book readers and how they feel
about on-air explosive diarrhea
so I'm a touch concerned well if you
want to look at the wine glass is half
full that happened to Bobbie Lee and it
was like a top-five trending video
millions and millions of views
situations so if that happens we're
moving some units we're shooting right
to the top of the bestsellers list so
fingers crossed thanks Bobby my mouth is
like already watering just in
anticipation of this humiliation here we
go
[Music]
it doesn't matter which direction we
start or would it really does matter
oh so you want to start towards the
paddle oh there are do we cut out the
middleman for okay
Agra I'm also hungry mildly hungover
from last night so that's actually
amazing so far so I wanna start by
taking it back to Pleasanton California
because it's important that people know
Dwayne Wade is not the only basketball
star in the family he is not ya know
does it ever get competitive when you
guys hoop does the foothill Falcon and
you ever come out she comes out often so
with my husband inside I feel like you
know they say any given team on any
given day can beat anybody that's always
how I feel like today's the day he's
going to and then speaking of love and
basketball some of our viewers might be
surprised to learn that you dated Jason
Kidd in high school now coach of the
Milwaukee Bucks and I was very surprised
to learn that he broke up with you via a
thumbs down three weeks before junior
prom with my father standing there is
that the most savage breakup of all time
was that just the coward's way out
before text messaging and snapchat it
stuck with me that's where the Karma was
like Oh [ __ ] there you are because all
the [ __ ] that you've been doing to these
poor people Here I am look at fire yeah
Christel okay okay so your resume is an
actress is so vast from big box office
smashes to these cult classics but the
real ones know that it all started with
Saved by the Bell the new class what did
you learn walking with Giants like mr.
Belding and screech I learned a lot
actually they were the first like big
stars I'd work with and so I just
watched him I would literally just sit
in the in the stands and I watched how
they talk to other people and how they
interact with the cast I watched how
they like got their timing together for
like their physical comedy their masters
a lot of people don't give a screech the
comedic genius appreciation that he
deserves and then to when we had Padma
Lakshmi on the show she talked about how
she did one episode of Star Trek
Enterprise and has been getting fan mail
for it 15 years later yes is the iron
still hot from playing and Klingon in
deep space 9 yes and specifically
because I was a Klingon in a very
special episode that introduced Worf son
that and after complex ran my swimsuit
issue my prison correspondents really
saw an uptick so I feel you know between
the Trekkies and the prisoners I'm I'm
pretty covered
[Music]
it does it is missing like some other
flavors though the flavor profiles not
hitting you the way you want it no well
that's such a lovely segue I love when
that happens in hot ones because Dwayne
Wade's now reunited with LeBron and
Cleveland the bromance is stronger than
ever stronger than ever so with that in
mind mm-hmm I want to ask you about
something that Dwayne said to food and
wine last year and I quote this might
get me in trouble I would have LeBron
order for me before I would let my wife
she'd get me nine different things to be
sure there's something I like LeBron
just knows literally my husband did not
eat anything green or any seafood like
at all for the bulk of our marriage and
then bran comes they become the he Dalls
and suddenly he's like I love sea bass
I've always loved Cena no no no no you
didn't you didn't love sea bass like
where did you even hear of sea bass he
was like bran he made me eat sea bass
and I love it now I'm like well what
else has brought introduced and he's
like salad so thanks bran the Future
Farmers of America thank you and then I
know that the wine is just important as
the food with you guys
Dwayne he has his own line you see
LeBron on Instagram all the time and as
we know wine very important to the
Gabrielle Union brand yes who's the real
connoisseur of the group yeah Mel is
he's like super well-versed in all
things wine he's like a wine savant
didn't see it coming did you I didn't
know um like you when you go on those
wine tours I just get drunk I may be
like it you know like incorporate a
couple things that they say but Mel is
like actually like listens and studies
and then goes home and does like more
research he's he's like like a whiny
you know this has a flavor not the other
one was lacking this is clearly not from
Portland yeah scotch bonnet and ginger
hot sauce this is really good so I have
a nine good authority that you host some
of the best parties and show business
and if the IG posts are any indication
the guest list it's always a plus who on
the list would you describe as like the
must-attend who is the life of the party
bran is always a very good time cuz he
dances actually he's in the room
somewhere Larry Sims
he's a former Missy Elliott dancer
turned hair stylist to the stars he will
break out the old choreography he'll
turn the place out yeah and he was also
in stomp the yard which for whatever
reason my husband is obsessed that Larry
was in stomp the yard and he does this
and he fries frames it and every time
because Tom PR is actually on a lot at
the scene it I get it
[Music]
another good flavor for one a really
flavorful I hate hot dogs just as hot
all right Gabrielle so we have a
recurring segment on our show called
explain that Graham we do a deep dive on
our guest Instagram post interesting
pictures that need more context so I'll
show you the picture and then you just
tell me the bigger story does that sound
yeah all right laptop please I'm all in
your password oh no you're not I've got
caps in there I've got characters I've
got numbers huh I'm not worried about it
all right when I start deleting emails
you'll know what happened oh okay who's
the better interview bomber Gabrielle
Union or Chris Bosh me because I'd not
only give you funny faces but I'm I'm
you know gonna mildly you know give a
booty rub I just completely take over
you see he's he's mortified he's just
had him an amazing game at the garden
that was here those good some Knicks and
I couldn't himself and it we talked
about his missed free throws you hit
like a game-winner but I've but that's
what good coaches do you know they're
always raising the bar look I'm the
Bobby Knight of this relationship you
know maybe a chair has been thrown or
six
oh that's ten things it was a lot of our
first movie we're up in Tacoma at
University High School and we were
having a good time of our lives we
thought all movies were gonna be like
that where everyone hangs out together
everyone gets paid the same all of our
trailers are the same I got the two
girls fake IDs their parents signed them
over to me which is a huge mistake
you're not slowing my roll and then was
it true that Heath Ledger he used when
he was partying need to have the
didgeridoo yes he always had the
didgeridoo and he had a couple buddies
who came up from I think from Perth and
what they would all play it like it was
like I guess like you're forced to learn
the didgeridoo as an Australian and
because they all seem to know how to
play it I think it's like the equivalent
of the recorder of the or the tonette
like everyone in America uses hot cross
buns but they did it with like the
didgeridoo
[Music]
dirty dicks a bucket full of dirty dicks
here we go you're into it yeah
so speaking of Instagram you have one of
the more prolific approaches to a woman
crush Wednesday where you do these you
know sometimes essay lengths oh ma jizz
to people like zendaya Chrissy Teigen
Lala part of like the whole WCW thing is
just celebrating women because often
times were sort of painted as haters and
she just cannot take another woman shine
so I just want to shine as bright of a
light on as many women as possible which
women in the industry do you look up to
everyone who's been like girl I don't
want you to fail come here I got you
come here come here come here
you brought this [ __ ] it up so come here
let me let me talk to you now for a long
time I wasn't sure if Jennifer Lewis
actually knew my name cuz she called me
Barbie [ __ ] Barbie [ __ ] where's the
Bobby [ __ ] ring button Barbie [ __ ]
limb excite you wait [ __ ] it up now and
I was just like tell me where I'm
[ __ ] up
I am Barbie [ __ ] because this is where
it starts to get a little rough okay
[Music]
my sinuses are clearing mm-hmm when it
comes to vacation goals I think you'd be
hard-pressed to find a couple that does
it better than the wades whether it's
yacht life or wading through shallow
water with pigs you guys always do it
big and I have a feeling that you know
where this is going can you give me the
BTS on the Banana Boat situation whose
idea was it who put their credit card
down was as much fun as it looked okay
so I will take credit for the banana
boats fiasco or glory depending on how
you look at it the first year that we
started going on the couple trip LeBron
and Savannah they chose the boat they
chose the location and that boat had all
kinds of bells and whistles there was
like a three-story slide into the ocean
they had jet skis and then they had
other inflatable toys that could be
pulled behind the smaller boat called
the tender so I saw that Banana Boat and
I wanted to ride it sorry but I was like
okay who's coming with me and none of
the girls wanted to go so I had to try
to convince Braun and dscp to get on the
Banana Boat and it took some convincing
though we had not been photographed
everyone was convinced that we were
being surveilled and I was like no and
not everybody cares about us you guys no
one's gonna see us and if no one got is
coming down the slide or dancing or
whatever we're safe get over yourselves
yeah so we mount the Banana Boat I am in
front than my spouse and then I think
it's like season three yeah LeBron
bringing up the caboose yeah
and then the what they did not capture
which was actually the best part once we
have all mounted the banana that boat
took off and no one was really prepared
we were there for the initial jolts and
then he hung a hard left and we flew off
and landed like fate side face-first
like like all of our were like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that's all you heard in the
water it it hurt it was painful
but magically they only got us a stride
and then when that catches like a
wildfire does like do I never talk to
you afterwards like I told you we should
because as soon as the picture came out
because we were still on vacation when
the picture you know it was released I I
was that [ __ ] that really no one's
gonna see it huh
and this is called dabomb dabomb beyond
insanity okay they really drive that
point home all right yeah mmhmm yeah
still burning okay okay hmm
forgot I asked for [ __ ] almond milk I
was needing that the coolness of regular
holdy milk but I also am lactose
intolerant so I wasn't gonna try to add
to the area my gums are bleeding so we
couldn't have you on first we feast
without talking about food and I know
being 44 going on 23 it takes some
discipline but anyone who knows
Gabrielle Union knows that you do like
to throw down I do out of all of the
cities that you've landed in which has
the best food Atlanta they use real
butter they use lard shortening
and it makes everything taste better and
there's like heavy sauces
nobody's vegan no one's heard of gluten
it's just a magical place
speaking of magical places from someone
on the inside what's up with MBA players
fascination with the Cheesecake Factory
okay its meals you recognize we're now
starting to see meals you recognize and
portions that are reasonable and most
NBA players aren't max dudes every town
pretty much every NBA city pretty much
has a Cheesecake Factory so you don't
want to be experimenting with some super
expensive meal to eat the drooling
mm-hmm
sorry and now there's burping and I'm
I'm just become that old person this is
like [ __ ] it [ __ ] it I'm drooling I'm
losing control of my faculties which
players have you come across that are
Loki great cooks is there anyone who can
really do it in the kitchen Charles
Oakley
first of all there should be a statue of
oak in front of Madison Square Garden
fries um one night years ago I was
hosting a pride party as a white party
for some of the most gorgeous empowered
lesbians on the planet and I had been
daydreaming with Michael Jordan and
Charles Oakley and I was like you guys
should come like I bet you guys are
gonna be like a huge hit everyone's
gonna love you and I've never seen
Michael Jordan more categorically
ignored ever in life
okk later that night we ended up back at
his place and he is like a master chef
and we've gone to the grocery store and
got all this food and he introduced me
to candied bacon I mean I didn't know he
poured the syrup on like the the raw
bacon and baked it don't I tell you
[Music]
yeah Megadeth and there's an actual
[ __ ] skull and crossbones mm-hmm wait
when it says with liquid rage
[Music]
yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm feeling the rage
this is the same rage I felt in my first
marriage when I when I didn't ask him to
sign a prenup and I had to later write a
big check the liquid rage is [ __ ] so you
have some of the best return fire
Twitter fingers in the game there's been
many an internet troll who's been
humbled by way of the Gabrielle Union
quote tweet when you're scrolling your
mentions what are the sorts of red flags
that pop up the internet shenanigans
that you find hardest to tolerate one
that just stuck out with me like cuz I'm
reading about you know People magazine
was like you know her struggle with
infertility and then I see the comments
and this guy was like I bet she's
struggles with infertility because of
all those dicks what [ __ ] what what
what if [ __ ] all those dicks cause
infertility [ __ ] you wouldn't [ __ ]
be here that's what I wanted to tweet
but I didn't feel like it was helpful
for the topic of infertility for me to
question is how many dicks his mama
perhaps if I'd had but I was like is
there a like a dick threshold where
you're like I'm infertile now because
that dick was the straw that broke the
[ __ ] camel's back or the straw that
broke my pussy's back I don't know I'm
gonna had to go to his like in stick by
his letter in the rabbit hole yeah I'm
like who the [ __ ] are your you live at
home how do you know how many dicks I've
had that's usually like my trigger see
how it just happened yeah yeah that's
that liquid rage um and here comes this
nut yeah I'm gonna do the rest of it
like this cuz I don't think I can
control it now I think it's just nasal
drip
[Music]
we're almost to the top of the mountain
Gabrielle Union we have one more wing to
go has exploded yet so this is the last
dab we call it the last dab because it's
tradition around here to put a little
extra on the last wing you don't have to
if you don't want to Gabrielle Union
it's so thick it is a little epic that's
okay you don't have to be don't you know
well I mean now cuz you know I'm
competitive that's how you lured me in
[Music]
I'm gonna be like oh Jesus you just were
on you were on Ted television with just
not your time you get talking about
dicks and buckets of dicks and Jesus
Mary Joseph
we're from Omaha by the way I know
that's my Midwestern thing Cornhusker to
the death of you huh so the day I die
it's and it's a rough time right now all
right
[Music]
and there it comes mm-hmm
creeper for sure alright [ __ ] no not as
I meet a scab right when it keeps coming
okay
[Applause]
[Applause]
let's try this non-sleeping almond milk
yeah any port in the storm
all right Gabrielle Union as we've
discussed today you're a woman who wears
many hats actress author style icon but
I think that they're even more hidden
talents
than meet the eye while the hot sauce is
coursing through you can you explain
what you meant when you said that
working with LL Cool J and DMX brought
out your inner wrapper
take a lap we've had many laps okay so
that bathroom was a right now right
right okay just in case Jesus did you
know that that DMX loves the Golden
Girls and that's a fun that's a real fun
fact oh really
mm-hmm how do you know this because he
washes it in his trailer
there was a dog biting incident with one
of the PAS who was sent to go get him
for set and so after a while nobody
wanted to go get him and so I would be
sent to go get him because I'm a dog
person and he'd be like yeah have a
drink you know when's it gonna go
is it his bunny sorry leave uh drooling
we would we would have a Heineken and
sometimes a little crown and and we'd
watch the Golden Girls and he would
laugh hysterically I also had to do all
of his b-roll questions because they
were afraid of him
but so I was like I'm not asking DMX
about the cinematography like I'm you
know who doesn't care about the
cinematography [ __ ] DMX I'm just look
like I got like lip injections is that's
what's starting AB because that's what
it feels like here's what I would say
Gabrielle Union you look just as
dignified just as graceful just as
lovely after the last dab as you did
before Valentina that was a great DMX
story and look at what you did today
Gabrielle Union you cleared the board
you got on top of the hot sauces and now
there's nothing left to do but roll out
the red carpet for you Gabrielle Union
this camera this camera or this camera
let the people know what you have going
on in your life I've got my new book
we're gonna need more wine we just
announced me Ron Braun Dave Talbert we
partnered up but we have a TV show that
we just sold to ABC called white Dave
and you know for everyone who's just
really upset that BMJ is coming to a
close please send all your
correspondence 250 Curtis Jackson who
has taken sole responsibility for the
loss of jobs and your show so don't at
me at 50
[Music]
hey what's going on hot ones fans a
quick heads up the second annual complex
con is coming to Long Beach California
November 4th and 5th and you know first
we feast and hot ones are gonna be in
the building there's gonna be a live hot
ones taping we're gonna be doing a panel
with my buddies Andy Milonakis and Matty
Matheson the last dab will be for sale
it's a whole thing
total circus hope to see you there